le président sur la première question
concernant les demandes
monsieur crade a fait une demande de
carte professionnelle en 2013 c'est ça
et elle concernait les activités de
détectives privés
sur quels motifs sur quel bouton
question quel titre
d'une part parce qu'ils pouvaient
justifier dans sa qualité de réserviste
opérationnel de la gendarmerie nationale
d'une équivalence
mais il disposait également d'un diplôme
d'université d'enquêteurs privés livré
par l'université paris 2 et donc il lui
a été délivré dans un premier temps en
2013 une carte de détectives privés
il a demandé en 2014 l'extension de
cette carte à d'autres activités
en fait à toutes les autres activités de
sécurité privée et il l'a fait sur deux
va en remplissant de critères d'une part
une fois encore la moralité vérifier
comme enfin la moralité au regard des
textes du livre 6 du code de la sécurité
intérieure et deuxièmement au regard par
équivalence au regard de son passé de
façon de son passé de son expérience de
réservistes opérationnels de la
gendarmerie nationale donc il a une
carte professionnelle il dispose d'une
carte professionnelle qui couvre
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée tel que le définit le livre 6 du
code de la sécurité intérieure en
revanche quand à sa demande d'agrément
qu'il a fait aux le 4 avril 2018 sa
demande d'agrément deux dirigeants a été
implicitement rejeté dans la mesure où
le
le dossier était incomplet et pourquoi
le dossier était incomplet parce qu'il
ne pouvait justifier d'une qualification
professionnelle lui permettant de
diriger une société